[Music]
hello, how are you, my aunt greets you with
her brief informative for today, Monday, August 2,
the woman accused of killing her
7-year-old son and leaving his body
near Milan Springs appears in court
tomorrow, Friday, a judge will
charged samantha moreno rodriguez with
murder following the death of her son liam
you she remains inside the
clark county detention center a vigil
for enade officer michael bay is
planned for tomorrow night at
police memorial park all people
they are welcome may suffered an accident
following a chase on
interstate 15 he fought for his life
hospitalized for two days before
passing away sunday several friends and
family members gathered as he was transported from
the coroner's office to his funeral
sunday from lidieth se stadium  it
filled again but not with music but with
soccer fans in the grand final of
the gold cup 2021 the tickets for this
event sold out in minutes and
registered  It had an attendance of over 61,000
and this was the largest
recorded soccer event in
Nevada history People said there was not
much organization as traffic
and parking remain a
problem locals and tourists hope
this will improve for  riders season
and other events inside the new
stadium and now we turn to
the weather forecast we will have temperatures
reaching 105 degrees by today
the heat is expected to continue for the
rest of the week the extreme heat wave
returns to midweek with
temperatures  exceeding 110 degrees
remember to stay hydrated and not
expose yourself to the sun for several hours have
a nice Monday
I am Héctor Mejía and this was your brief
informative about them he spoke to me in Spanish
[Music]